Hi guys, I shoot a lot of trades today for you and I will now do the voiceover for the
Blood Sweat & Sculpt community, it will be an amazing content, I can guarantee you.
The last short spoiler, I took this absorption, will be floating 20,000, 30,000, no, 20,000
but I closed because now it's almost market closing so I would expect volatility to melt,
I close here and then another leg down, let's start with the first one, this one got recorded
without audio because I couldn't concentrate explaining and trading, so let me start from
the explanation, this one is the long-term value area high, this one is a crazy absorption,
this one is a crazy absorption and this one is where the sellers took complete control,
absorbed, failed auction, failed auction, failed auction, failed auction, so I marked this area,
okay, I was short biased today for the caught report and the data that I explained to you
and we started aggressively on the short side so I reconfirm my idea for the short and I was trying
to take the control of the seller, the explosion, because as you can see they were compressed,
so to take a 2,500 initial risk to make 30,000 on this one, I will go on and I will stop to
explain, let me see if there is something interesting here to explain other than the area
and the short I was expecting an acceleration down, I put now the NASDAQ profile area,
the NASDAQ effort area, so I have an area that is interesting, a failed auction value area high
and they see two cluster of NASDAQ effort, okay, so the initial stop loss was above the area
and then I printed the second one, so I put stop loss in profit and then it exploded in a crazy way
and now the last target is on the value area low, the bottom of the value area low,
but today was a really compressed day, we had some spark of directional but not a lot,
so now I want to show you how we start managing the trades as I do live with the NASDAQ effort,
so one area of control, I was waiting for the market to retrace to fill the area to put my
stop loss in profit, we do this and I start to put 7,900 and it's already almost 1 to 3.4 for our
in profit, another area we print here, so I'm covered above the area, I'm waiting for the
breakout of this area to put even more stop in profit, they manage to break out the area
to do one squeeze, I'm waiting for something to put my stop loss in profit here, it didn't
got tested, it got tested but we don't have a rejection, so now I'm waiting for a confirmation
of where to put 16,000 dollars of stop in profit and on this one unfortunately I don't get the
full profit target, I get 16,000 dollars with a total risk of 2,500, first position of the day,
I think I didn't manage to record two break even and one stop loss, but the majority of the most
interesting volatility I recorded, this one was a short, the reason is that we had an aggression
on the bottom side, so I can see that the sellers are really aggressive here and I'm trying to
capitalize on the short momentum of the market as you can see and this one if I'm not wrong it's a
kick on the face, it's a stop loss, if I'm not wrong the market accelerate and I lose 2,600,
to be honest 2,700 on this one because I get also a little bit of slippage,
you can always see the feeling of interactive brokers on the right when I get liquidated to
enjoy some pain than contracts NASDAQ, this one was the second one and was a stop loss unfortunately
was a reload, then we have one amazing short cluster of two areas, I shorted late guys,
this one I could have made a crazy risk to reward, I should have shorted at the second area on the
test, I shorted late, I shorted here and the initial risk was 2,500, then when we have a second
area I start to manage, the full profit target guys I was too generous with the profit target
in a choppy day because today we had some volatility but still compression, stop loss in profit
34,000 full profit on the position, the risk in 2,500 is crazy, the second victory was
risk to reward trade, I'm covered 17,000 above the aggression of the sellers and the absorption
of the buyers, I'm hoping that this area of the NASDAQ effort hold but I get a stop in profit here,
I put 18,600 on this one and I get stop in profit here, amazing position, one stop loss and two
high risk to reward profits, then I tried this short, this short is super easy to understand,
it's momentum down, it's a crazy absorption of the buyer's reward of the seller, I was trying
to anticipate a squeeze down, I don't remember if this one it's profit or I think it's stop loss
absorption here, my error in management, I also want to show you my error, when you see this
you need to close, okay, when you see this you need to close because it's a failed auction,
I kept the position and I pay 2,450 plus 100 dollars of slippage and I deserved it because
I made one error, showing you also the painful part, okay, let's wait, I want to show you the
pain of the liquidation here, a little bit before, here, snap, bam, okay, three or four tick of
slippage, then let's go on, this one still momentum short, failed auction at the top,
a lot of fight here, so I was anticipating a squeeze, I was thinking this is the last setup
of the day because I needed to go out but then I had time so the appointment got cancelled
and I could continue to use my profit for the day to capitalize even more, the reason was this crazy
absorption of the buyers and you can see from the profile that I put later, I'm taking 1,500
dollars of risk to make 19 600 dollars, so more than 1 to 10 risk to reward, to be honest the
initial risk was 2,500 and if I'm not wrong I also give some breathing to the market because I was
afraid I can get weak out and then the setup it's amazing and still loading, if I'm not wrong this
one goes stopping profit really fast, I put myself stopping profit on this retracement,
here we go 240 dollars and then we have a collapse down, beautiful setup, the most beautiful of the
day, I was expecting a squeeze, the momentum was short, the bias on the fundamental was short,
I managed the position stopping profit 13 140 on the momentum side, long give the possibility
to the market to take all the profit back from me, 107 absorbed at the bottom,
gap, I love this gap, I usually wait for it to get recovered and then put stop loss in profit
and this one don't give me even the time because goes to full profit target for the day, it's the
first crazy risk to reward trade for the day, let's see this one, ah this one is amazing,
this one it's amazing, I took, let me explain for you, this one it's a value area high,
it's absorption of the buyers, reabsorption of the buyers, reabsorption of the buyers again,
domination of the sellers and test, I took a perfect test here 2500 initial risk reduced to
1920, profit target disabsorption of the sellers, was anticipating a squeeze here,
I don't remember this one if it goes all back, no this one is another full profit target,
should be and also continue, like this one could have been 25 000, full take profit,
look how much is beautiful, look at this beauty, absorption, absorption, absorption,
dominion of the sellers, absorption, this is textbook, okay, beautiful, then
let me check, this is an error, this is an error, this is a stupid error that I've made,
still when you get professional you take some discretionary decision that should be avoided,
this one could have been guys, okay, a squeeze short, but when you see 200 contract absorbed here,
you cannot still stay stopping breakeven, because this one was an additional 9 000
dollars of profit for the day, okay, and this one goes full back to breakeven or stopping profit,
I don't remember, I think stopping profit, yes, 1260 gets taken out,
this one was mismanagement, because this one should have been a full profit target
of 10 000, 9 000 dollars, I don't remember,
I was waiting for the big direction short, and now I show you something funny, because the big
direction short arrived at the closing, but I didn't manage to take it,
let me avoid the choppiness for you, so you only get the interesting part,
I think this live trading commentary pill of the volatility session, it's incredibly interesting
for you guys, oh, never take
absorption of the sellers, where is it, I want to show you all the filling of the position,
feel the suffering, read the message at the bottom, one, two, three,
nine contract close, in one, two, three, second,
um, closed, this one was a stop in profits, a stupid decision I took,
now it comes the masterpiece of the day, at the closing, guys, look how much is beautiful,
this setup, value area high, crazy absorption level, absorbed buyers, control of the sellers,
not even the time to put the position, 2000 risk already, one, two, three,
was really late, closing of the session, guys,
okay, the market start to consolidate here, I close for around 5000 or 6000, something like this,
okay, and now it went even more down, look,
this one could have been another $20,000 for the session, this was the commentary of the session,
guys, I think you can learn more than everything else by me recording myself when I have a high
volatility session, not directional, but high volatility, let me know what do you think,
and I think this one is amazing, it's an amazing learning opportunity for you all,